Grant Williams on the side got it Bryant
and fire over three now rebound Cloud a
second of Defenders knocked away in a
foul it may have been cable Martin and
Miami was in that zone there and the
problem when you're in a Zone you don't
have box out responsibilities and brown
just goes right over the top of Laura
were there to get that off defensive
rebound and is headed to the free-throw
line Lowry got the foul
he's upset about something he thought he
got hit oh in the hand yeah he wants to
look at a uh
hostile act and Zach zarber just said no
they're not gonna do that but now brown
and Lowry John a little bit oh no here
they go on Lowry is up on him and uh has
to be some separation
Brown said something
and while we were standing about five
feet in back and then he walked to him
as brown was ready to shoot the free
throw
well one thing Reggie with Miami they
play Kyle Lowry always in the back of
that zone when the ball is shot
particularly from the other side as
tough as Kyle Lowry he is he's giving
away a lot of sides on the weak side
rebound and brown was just able to go
over the top
and brown took a fence to the swiping
and he's like you know exactly what you
did Lowry comes back with his rebuttal
and this is what you expect so these
guys are seeing each other five times
already
[Applause]